you've seen his face before
maybe hundreds of times depending on how
much you like ice cream
he's been with you in times of great joy
maybe consoled you after a breakup
making life a little bit better one pint
at a time
and there he is hello the company jerry
greenfield created with his childhood
friend ben cohen
helped define what a modern company
could be
[Applause]
taking stands often uncomfortably ahead
of or at odds with public opinion
there was a lot of criticism there was a
lot of skepticism
even from the inside of the company
i spoke to jerry to find out how he
built a global business
without compromising his social
conscience you can be
the most caring company in the world you
can use the most responsibly sourced
ingredients
but if the ice cream doesn't taste
great it's all for naught
so there are so many places i i thought
about starting with you
jerry so let's go back let's go back to
the beginning
how much of the original ethos
was like baked in as it were like
right from the beginning like what is it
what is the
essence of it as you look back on those
early days
certainly ben and i are
uh products of our upbringing
and our environment we grew up in the
60s
i don't know that we were hardcore
hippies per se
but we certainly believe in peace and
love not as a cliche but
that we're all in this together and our
role as human beings is to help take
care of each other
so when we started as a little homemade
ice cream shop
our idea was to be a little corner store
that would be a community gathering
place and
we actually had no thoughts of being a
business
we wanted the shop to be a reflection
of who we were and so when did you know
it was a business
the first time it really seemed like a
business
was when we built an
ice cream factory
we started packaging ice cream only
because
we couldn't really make it as an ice
cream shop it was too cold in vermont
so we built a real
mechanized ice cream plant and
ben and i were there one day watching
these pint containers
come out of the ice cream machine and it
was just
pint after pint after pint and gallon
after gallon after gallon
and we said boy somebody's eating a lot
of ice cream out there
you know that that's kind of when it
sunk in hi i'm ben
i'm jerry you know we may not have the
money to go on tv for 30 seconds but we
sure do make some of the best ice cream
you ever tasted
talk to me about your relationship with
him you guys knew each other
as kids i have to say you know i've
looked at a lot of partnerships
over the course of my reporting career
there are very few
that match up to this like how do you
explain that
uh i think we really really appreciate
and treasure our friendship which is
kind of at the bottom of everything
and so we have a very similar
world view and view of what we would
like the business to be
starting with an anti-authoritarian
bent which is kind of the fundamental
part of ben
he's very counter-cultural he's
extremely creative
so it's pretty unusual stuff
that countercultural approach was baked
in from the beginning and not especially
methodical
the pair drew on a world view that
started as kids was cultivated through
their adolescence and early adulthood
and never really left them when you talk
about the
the social mission it doesn't feel like
you're doing a lot of market research
about like well we should weigh in on
this issue where we shouldn't weigh in
on that issue right
no it's uh it's based on values
things like environmental justice
and no fairness
in bombing and killing and drone
striking
other people like us and standing up
for people whose voices are often
not heard and that's you know pretty
different
from a corporate approach
and do you think it it helped hurt or
was neutral that you're you're selling
ice cream
throughout all of this you're not a you
know a big bad corporation you're you
know you're selling chunky monkey and
cherry garcia
i think it really helped making ice
cream is something that
has allowed ben and jerry's to
talk about pretty serious issues
uh get involved in pretty serious issues
and combine it with ice cream
and it allows us to talk with people and
connect with people
about serious things in a pretty fun way
but in the end it all comes down to the
ice cream
and if the ice cream doesn't taste
great it's all for naught
so you still have to do all the other
business stuff that an ice cream company
does you have to make great ice cream
you need to get it distributed
you need to make sure it's kept cold so
it's kind of interesting sometimes
people think it's a
magic bullet if you have a social
conscience
and in a way it makes things more
complex
so you know this notion of exactly what
you're talking about
actually does lead me to to this clip
that that i want you to watch
and it's from chico lager
fred lager who goes by chico served as
the general manager and later ceo of ben
and jerry's
back in the early 1980s to be honest
i mean there was this tension
between the urge of the founders
to be more social mission driven
and the responsibility that myself and
my management team felt
to make money to make a profit and to
deliver
a return to the shareholders you know
you want to sell you're selling ice
cream you're selling a fun
product and everybody eats ice cream but
not everybody believes in the values
that ben and jerry held and the question
is do you want to alienate
half the population that perhaps doesn't
agree with everything that you're
advocating for
in hindsight it worked because
the people who were attracted to the
business became fiercely loyal
and wanted to support the business more
and more
and you know i have plenty of republican
friends and they still eat the ice cream
because it tastes really really good
but there was this tension there's no
denying it ben and jerry and i are
are still very close and good friends
and you know all of us look back on it
and go you know
boy you know we all could have figured
out a way to have done that
in a much more amiable way and with a
little less
drama and wish that we had but
really good things emerged you know from
that tension
and ultimately i think resulted
in a business that was uh both
successful financially but also
succeeded on a product and social basis
as well
you should just do your entire interview
with chica
he sort of summed a lot up there didn't
he
yeah chico's great yeah so when you look
back to you know like
building the team and all of that and
you know it's not just the the
two of you very quickly you sort of do
have to
draw consensus and you're walking these
lines in many ways and
it's not easy it's not easy and i think
there was this
struggle there was this what are we
going to be
as a business are we going to be more of
a
traditional business let's say or are we
going to
try to do something different and i
think it's helpful to understand that
back at that time there really weren't
a lot of businesses doing it and there
were no books about how to do it
and you didn't know where it was going
to take it
and the time that
we were really trying to decide what are
we going to be
ben essentially said all right we're
doing it
and you're either on the bus or you're
off the bus
and when you say you're on the bus
meaning we're going to be a company of
purpose and mission
and that that's who we are and we're
either gonna
do it or die trying yeah but
you know the other amazing thing about
ben is i don't think he ever had any
doubt that it was gonna work you know
ben viewed this as an experiment
he didn't view it as oh we need to make
a successful business
he viewed it as let's see what we can do
let's see what business can be
for ben and jerry following their
consciences hasn't just meant
prioritizing a social mission
it's also meant repeatedly wading into
some of the most controversial issues
of the day
when you think of that sort of activism
evolving you know and choosing specific
issues and same-sex marriage i think is
a really interesting one
stepping out in that way required a
certain amount of
courage especially when you're in charge
of the livelihoods of
lots of people yeah the
first time was the hardest and that was
back kind of in the early 90s
during the cold war ben and jerry's
came out with a product a chocolate
covered ice cream bar on a stick and
decided to call it a peace pop
and on the packaging it talked about
redirecting one percent of the military
budget
out of weapons and into peace through
understanding
activities and there was this fear that
people were going to boycott us that
distributors wouldn't distribute the
product
that supermarkets wouldn't carry the
product
we were going to be seen as unpatriotic
but even people who didn't agree
could respect the fact that the company
was
taking a position on an issue
that was in the common good
but lofty ideals didn't seem to jive
with the controversial decision by ben
and jerry's
to sell itself to multinational
corporate giant unilever
in 2000. both ben and i
did not want to sell the company ben
very very strongly so ben would have
done
anything to not sell the company because
any acquiring company
would likely not passionately share the
social values that ben and jerry's had
and
it turns out we couldn't stop the sale
because at the time ben and jerry's was
a public company
which meant anybody could purchase
shares and
in truth the first several years
after ben and jerry's was acquired it
wasn't great
i think unilever didn't understand and
appreciate the mission of the company
and it wasn't until about 10 years ago
when there was a new ceo at unilever and
they
put in a new ceo at ben and jerry's that
things really got
better many of these issues of food
security
or employment or climate change cannot
be managed by focusing on the quarter to
quarter
you have to be sure that we value things
that count paul pullman
had a genuine commitment to
sustainability
and the person at ben and jerry's josten
solheim
really believed in the mission of the
company was a real risk taker
so when ben and jerry's was speaking out
for same-sex marriage and when ben
juries
publicly supported occupy wall street
[Applause]
which was essentially an anti-corporate
movement
and in 2015 when the company
publicly supported black lives matter
when george floyd was killed in the
summer of last year ben and jerry's
released a powerful statement calling
for the
end of white supremacy it was startling
in its specificity and clarity
especially as other companies chose much
more cautious language
but being careful isn't the way the
place is built
and this wasn't new ground i think the
company was
able to speak out so strongly and so
clearly because it had been doing the
work
for the last five years it wasn't as if
the george floyd murder happened and the
company said
well we got to do something about it the
company
publicly supported black lives matter in
2015
it's done work in north carolina around
voter rights and voter suppression
working with the naacp the company
two years ago came out with a flavor
called
justice remixed which was
around several issues but one of them
was
about racial justice and criminal
justice
and so that led up to the george floyd
murder and the company
being able to say we must dismantle
white supremacy
and to ben and me one of the most
wonderful things
is that we had nothing to do with it uh
people probably don't realize ben and i
work at the company but we're not
involved in the management
we're kind of pretty faces you know
we're ben and jerry
and we had no involvement in that in
that the company
came out very strong and
it was wonderful and so as as we wrap up
i i want to talk about that because
you know there are very few people very
few people who
literally put their name on something
that becomes a
a global brand and i mean what is the
feeling of
opening up a freezer or walking into a
store and like
that's your name on on uh on a pint of
ice cream what does that feel like
uh i will say i don't connect
that much when i open up a freezer door
and look at a pint of ben and jerry's
[Music]
when i think about the 43 years of ben
and jerry's i think about
my my friendship with ben doing some
crazy adventures
as part of the business using its voice
to speak
out on issues that are controversial
and i think about how lucky
i am i try to explain this for people
that
you know being jerry from ben and
jerry's whenever i meet anybody
they just automatically are warm
and trusting and assume
good things about me and everybody
ought to have the opportunity to go
through life where
people you meet are warm and trusting
and
friendly it's it's an amazing thing
you